ouais pour ceux qui connaissent pas
c'est une émission sérieuse avec des
thèmes sérieux et surtout un cyril
hanouna sérieux alors si riche c'est que
vous pouvez pas vous empêcher d'injecter
un petit peu de barca a levé tôt écoutez
par exemple les noms de certains
intervenants de balances ton post
réponse de linda juste si elle répond
sans mention d'un kebab et on a mais
ahmed amadeus mac connaissez racheal de
wolf gang m qni est avec nous merci m
kuhn et ont fait pas exprès je vous dis
aujourd'hui tout le monde voulait voir
comment allait fonctionner votre duo
avec madame la ministre
alors je rappelle que certains
journalistes vous présentez comme les
nouveaux fred et jamy 5 était formidable
alors votre relation mais très bien
commencé mais comme dans un couple
castaldi ça n'a pas duré
merci d'être là en tout cas c'est
courageux de buck tard de devenir voulez
vous asseoir peut-être ça va jusqu ici
pas bien ça très bien très proche 33 cm
oui comme jean michel maire mais marlène
schiappa vous touche beaucoup beaucoup
fait m'a ramené chez vous et rétabliront
série avant la proposition ça vous
dérange à l'explosif c'est qu'on soit
deux points et comme maxime kenny vous
n'avez pas quand vous tripote je n'ai
pas ça du tout alors vous allez trouver
la solution vous allez voir vous
éloigner le sujet c'est que c'était des
gens qui nourrissent ils vont y avait
trop tard en france
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le guet passant comtois c'est vrai j'ai
très peur vous quitter le plateau
sept mètres 80 kmh cyril hanouna c'est
plus de 3000 animations des missions
mais aussi d'immunisation de bar mitsva
et bien sûr et je peux vous dire que
vendredi soir sur le plateau ministre ou
ministre
c'était vous chef tout le monde vous
écoute c'est impressionnant regarder
cette maîtrise ou la vérité messi qui a
parlé la raison de confirmer ses bons et
tout le monde s'en fout personne ne vous
écoute
comment diantre je n'ai aucune autorité
ce matin comme tous les jours vous était
sur ses news
alors on va tellement souvent dans bakou
fait des interviews en pyjama on a vu là
alors avant dans la rue quand vous
croisez quelqu'un et vous disais vas-y
frérot fois une playstation ouais sauf
maintenant c'est une nouvelle depuis
vendredi une nouvelle question qu'on me
pose
on vous dit vas-y frérot connaissent que
tu te lance en politique c'est vrai ou
pas c'est vrai alors tout le monde les
voit pas si si donc c'est tout ce que
vous êtes actuellement le patron de
canal+ mais là rien arriver sur wii je
peux c'est ma fiche de paye j'avais su
j'aurais sauté je vais sauter alors en
2022 vous serez le patron mais de ceux
ci si harry potter c'est comme la
république et cyril et noir avec 120 %
des votes
jean bringer magouilles et gemma noyés
alors trublion journaliste politique sa
cause est tiraillé entre vos deux
personnellement fait c'est plein la
gueule un jeu mais alors là vous à
tirailler entretenue entre donc un peu
quand bernard montiel qui est blanc à
l'intérieur et orange à l'extérieur
alors regarder mourir de rire
alors d'abord son poste vendredi vous
êtes un peu comme james bond en costume
trois pièces alors dans tpm fait vous
montrez votre service trois pièces n'a
rien à voir c'est pas de bol le vent de
la houle était ce un bon soir à toucher
ainsi les titres du jour
versailles mousty notre ami françois
l'avocat augmenter les salaires avons
juste des âmes à le baisser un petit peu
alors pour garder btp faut qu'il fait
les chiffres et on commence avec ceux
d'isabelle morini-bosc main sur 1150
euros vous payer 150 euros de mutuelles
le client paye l'un par un sentiment
aujourd'hui de tva seulement tiflis avec
une taxe à 20 % 960 millions d'une pompe
comprise entre 5% et 8% sur deux mètres
de longueur le smic seun est réservé
mais moi j'ai rien compris j'ai pas vu
alors que dans tpm paix franchement moi
je comprends tout voilà nous dotons pu
frérot faire alors cyril pour finir
sachez que vendredi soir devant balance
mon poste j'avais les larmes aux yeux
c'est normal qu'à 4 heures du matin
toujours devant la télé j'avais les yeux
défoncé c'est aussi un petit peu ça mais
plus sérieusement tout au long de
l'émission vous nous avez foutu les
poils regardez moi ces lycées par mon
émission c'est pas démission de la
ministre
c'est votre émission ces démissions des
français lui faut aussi savoir partagé
moi j'ai toujours été avec vous parce
qu'on est on est ensemble
ce soir c'est ni les missions des
chroniqueurs ni démission de la ministre
ni mon émission c'est votre émission
[Applaudissements]